[موسيقى]
انا سوء يستخدمون مصطلح الماكرونيه
السياسيه فهل هناك فكر سياسي مكروني اعتقد
ان هذا الامر مختلف الرئيس مكحون نفسه قال
انه يريد ان يختار قليلا من هنا وهناك ولا
نستطيع ان نقوله هناك عقيده في المكرونيه
اما ديكوريه فهي فكر وتصور في اطار علاقات
بين الناس وتاليا لفرنسا دور على المستوى
الدولي من اجل المساعده على توطيد
الاستقرار والسلام في العالم وحتى لا يكون
هناك استقطاب ثنائي في العالم في السابق
كانت بين الاتحاد السوفياتي والولايات
المتحده واليوم هي بين الولايات المتحده
والصين اذا كان يجب تلا في هذا الاستقطاب
الثنائي الذي يمكن ان يؤدي الى مواجهه
يمكن لفرنسا ان تلعب دورا من خلال تقديم
طريق ثالث لجمع من لا يريدون الاصطفاف الى
جانب الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا او الصين
حاليا او الولايات المتحده لانهم يودون
الحفاظ على هويتهم وعلى استقلالهم اذا على
المستوى الدولي هذه هي السياسه
[موسيقى]
ولايات المتحده هي خليفه لنا وصديقه ولكن
علينا ان ندرك ان الولايات المتحده تحاول
دائما تمريره مصالحها الوطنيه قبل مصالح
حلفائها واصدقائها وفي شكل العامه كل دوله
تهدف في النهايه الى تحقيق مصالحها يجب
تاليا ان يكون هناك حوار حازم ملؤه الثقه
مع الحلفاء والاصدقاء لا اعتقد ان فرنسا
تصف اليوم خلف الولايات المتحده هناك نقاط
مشتركه وصداقه ولكن هناك ايضا مواقف قد
تكون مختلفه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]